oh honey i'm in and kathy you're in do i
bring my scissors with me and my dental
supplies
oh my god kyle can we jump in and just
talk about kathy cause that's what the
internet wants to talk about
yes i mean what a gift to the world of
housewives your sister
is that we didn't know we needed i mean
i remember talking to you a few years
ago and you said it's never really been
a conversation
for kathy to come on board the show so
what changed
it it did come up initially but they
felt like it would be very
sister heavy with having three sisters
on the housewives
um and then it didn't come up again and
then we weren't speaking
and then this last time it was my idea
and i just said you know what about
bringing my sister kathy and that's how
it came about a lot of people thought
oh bravo's pulling a fast one on kyle no
it was actually me
um suggesting it you've always said
she's a character she's hilarious like
people don't know
people's perception of who kathy hilton
is is not at all who she is which we are
learning has anything that she's done on
the show so far
surprised you no not at all
i mean you know this is a perfect
example of people thinking they know
like a public figure and then you know
getting to see them you know in a
different light like this
cathy what are you out of your mind
what is this a red bull i thought it was
like just a soft drink
my question is like how did kyle turn
out seemingly so normal
with these all my love to your sisters
but they're a little bit of a wackadoo
compared to you
well um one of our um our showrunner
chris cullen
for many years on our show used to call
me marilyn munster so
i think that fits you can't be too
careful these days
there are a lot of strange people in
this world kathy has given us so much in
just like three episodes does anything
top the midnight madness in lake tahoe
you know there's so many um funny
moments like that that
are just hysterical i mean there's some
times when we had to go you know
drive on trips she's never driven like
on a two-hour road trip so
trying to explain to her weighs an apple
id password
no ma'am you have no idea what a
situation that was
[Laughter]
i can only imagine she's so um
in her own world sometimes it's when she
doesn't know she's funny that really
kills me though
how are you go ahead wait i thought you
were kyle
i'm not kidding i get that all the time
she is
naturally a funny person but then she's
just by way of living her life also
funny
i noticed that first on instagram
because kathy's instagram comments are
always
a journey she's like trying to set up
meetings and lunches and get personal
information out of people
she's been using twitter as like an
answering service for years can you guys
please tell kyle in paris to call me
trying to get a hold of them
and people would like message me on
instagram saying your sister's looking
for you can you call her
strangers so you know this is something
i would try to explain to people before
and i was like i i don't think you
understand my sister like it's
it's nothing you've ever experienced
what are you doing well i know i was
embarrassed the way i look
no i'm not people seeing you and kathy
have such a good time is
making people miss the kim days a little
bit the good kim days
not season one season two more like
season three season four
right um where are you at with kim now
we're all in a good place right now
thank god um and i would love to see
kim come back it'll be fun yeah we need
to see the three of you on a girl's trip
oh my god i mean it will be fun until
it's not
someone was like you guys should do
below deck the three sisters and i'm
like
overboard yeah i don't know if i think
you need a
a clean escape you can't be out and then
stranded in the water
yeah and housewives and boats just never
never really go over that well
yeah that's i think is mentioned on this
next episode coming up
uh you're back on a boat um this episode
kicks off kind of the erica of it all
what what is going on did you have any
idea no idea
it's erica so she had to do it like this
she couldn't tell anybody
what the hell i know we're gonna watch
and see what happens
um but knowing everything you know that
she's shared with you
how do you think the viewers are gonna
feel at season's end are the answers
there
to me you know it's easy to judge
someone you know on
reality television and when the audience
watches the show they have to remember
this was six months ago
it was literally unfolding as we were
filming
so every day it was another headline
another story coming out
and you know some of them were
devastating and i'm sure you know
some people think oh she knew and you
know all that shady stuff they're
talking about but
you really don't know and if you know
erica you think well
why would she have known all of this
stuff like i don't feel that tom girardi
one of the biggest attorneys in the
world was going home and sharing things
happening at his firm
with his wife that's not the
relationship they had so
um but you know you're going to see a
lot of that unfold and
she has a very very difficult time as
you know i mean it's a very difficult
time in her life right now
i think it's important to remember you
are innocent until proven guilty in this
country and i feel like a lot of people
have
stamped her as guilty listen that's what
i said you're innocent until proven
guilty
and also you know as a friend i can
support you
i'm not defending because i don't know
anything
i mean i don't know so i'm not going to
sit there and say i know for a fact so
i'm going to defend no i don't know
so i'm i'm there to support not defend
orphans and widows
it makes you feel sick did you know any
of this
no one knows the answer but him
is there anything though that we should
be bracing for impact for or that you're
bracing for impact for
oh yeah there's many things that we had
to brace for impact and
it honestly was waking up every day and
then just kind of watching her life
um i mean i don't know
like for lack of a better word like
crumbling before her eyes
and you know it's gonna be a very
challenging season for her
and also for some other cast members
with some of the relationship stuff so
it won't disappoint one relationship
that we hear talked about in the trailer
is the
scott disick amelia hamlin relationship
i'm going with my friend
he's too damn old he's old and you've
got three kids
can't help but wonder that this had to
have come up in one of your
chats with kris jenner like you've had
to have said this is strange
well i mean listen i'm a mother of four
daughters so
i i wouldn't be happy with that
situation i just wouldn't
but you know i also know that you know
rena's daughter's an adult and it's not
like she's gonna listen to what rena
says anyway
but that doesn't stop me from voicing my
opinion about it
i'm sure that she and scott don't love
that i said that but
that's how i how i feel you know it's
just it's it's kind of funny to me too
also because
you know i know courtney and i know
courtney and
scott as being together so it's all kind
of strange for me anyway when i see that
well i think it's just a reminder that
the world is so small
it's way too small around here let me
tell you this town is a game of chess
but no one's taken this queen down will
you ever retire using
in this town in beverly hills in your
taglines
thank you for asking me that so i see
all the comments
trust me there's so many like there were
as many as there was if she ever says in
this town
in this town my town i'm from this town
ever again i'm gonna scream and then
the other half were like she has to say
that at this point that she needs to say
that
i think i can never ever say it again no
matter how much they want me to
i have to put my foot down i don't know
it's like your calling card at this
point it's almost like you see that
people say but then people say if you
ever do the splits again i'm going to
kill you and then
then people say do the splits do the
splits and i'm you know out of
doing something have a couple drinks i
don't know why i just do them it's like
my party trick i have other party tricks
i'm gonna
pulling new party tricks out of the bag
you damned if you don't think which i
think is kind of what has happened
in the whole lvp autographed dinner saga
of like
you guys have to answer questions
because if you don't then people will
say
oh she's avoiding talking about it but
is there anything left to say to that
topic
no i literally
am not i mean i'm not even gonna
i'm gonna leave it there so i can only
say i didn't
in some recent interviews some of your
co-stars got some flack for saying
garcelle is the most
inauthentic of the group um do you
agree with that sentiment or no well for
me
when they said that i kind of understood
that in a sense because
you know her first season i thought she
liked me and we were getting along and
having the best time
and then i would see interview bites or
things that she was saying like when she
said oh kyle looked hideous tonight and
then she'd kind of giggle i was like
that that's that did feel inauthentic to
me honestly because i was like if you if
i don't like you you're gonna know it
you know i'm gonna say to your face i'm
not gonna be nice and save it for my
interview
so in that aspect i understand um
but you know we had our talk we spoke
through things and
we really understood each other more
after that and i'm just happy to move
forward and laugh and have fun with her
there's some fan speculation i'm sure
you've seen it
that the fox force five gangs up every
year and like plots out a plan to take
one person down
what's your response to that a lot i
don't
first of all there's never ever a plot
you know
to take anybody down you know if things
unfold and then we go with whatever is
unfolding what's happening in people's
lives at the time
i think people don't like that there's a
um a bond between
the five of us there's a lot of trust
between us
and these are relationships we've had
for many many years now
and these are kind of like newer girls
and you know there's stuff going on you
want to talk about and share
not everyone's invited every time so
there's no trying to exclude i mean
garcelle and some have dinner and you
know we're not invited no big deal
can we talk a little bit about mashup
show i know you probably can't say yes
um what's the one word you would use to
describe that experience
eye opening so that and also it was
unbelievably exhausting nobody could
ever imagine i'm not even kidding you
we don't if we don't shoot like that and
you know on our show and the other shows
don't either but
i would wake up and a light would a a
light over my head a production light
would go on at 7 00 am
i was like what this is this is like big
brother yeah
it was a little chaos and like literally
zero down time
at all but it was interesting because
seeing the other franchises and being a
housewife myself
um you know i also have preconceived
ideas about people
i watch the show i'm a fan of the other
housewives shows
and it was really interesting to like
have a completely
different take on people that i never
imagined
so that was really interesting and kind
of analyzing how they all operate and
who's like
more playing to the cameras who's
completely you know not thinking about
the cameras and
this it was a big lesson there i think i
saw you say in a different interview
that um
you guys get to break the fourth wall
that it's not gonna be like i called all
my girlfriends up to get together for
this trip like you guys get to talk
about
housewives and being on the show yeah i
mean that's the only way you can do it
who would you say had the best uh
vacation experience you know
i want to say maybe teresa maybe melissa
except theresa was really missing her
boyfriend
a lot like i mean
i we teased her so much because she was
like louie this and louie that louie
this and look at that
and then at one point she was taking a
picture of a hammock i said what are you
doing she goes louie loves hammocks and
i was like
you better take a picture of a hammock
because louie loves hammocks like
it was really funny
you